مصر تنتظر الحدث الكبير هذا العام هو
افتتاح المتحف المصري الكبير اعطينا فكره
عن هذا المتحف والاستعدادات الجديده
همم
والاستعدادات على قدم مستقل افتتاح رسمي
للمتحف المصري الكبير ال- اا ال- ال-
المتحف ده يعني وضع همم حجر الاساس بتاعه
من 20 سنه تقريبا همم وتوقف لفتره بعد
الثوره ال- ال- البناء ورجع ثاني همم بقى
لهم سنتين بيستعدوا لهذا الحفل اللي
المفروض هيكون اسطوري همم في خلال سته
اشهر القادمه وهيستمر عده ايام هيحضره
زعماء وملوك من جميع انحاء العالم المتحف
ده على مساحه 117 فدان موجود هنا عند
الاهرامات وبيطل على الاهرامات همم هيكون
في حوالي 50,000 قطعه اثريه يمكن اهمها
لاول مره هتعرض المجموعه الكامله ل همم
اثار الملك توت عنخ امون حوالي 5000 قطعه
هتعرض كلها مع بعض وفي مجموعه والده الملك
خوفو مراكب الشمس يعني عدد كبير من ستار
ايضا هناك معمل للترميم همم بالمتحف وطبعا
اساليب العرض هتبقى همم وفق احدث الاساليب
العربيه الحديثه سمر صباح العربيه وفريق
العربيه بانتظارك المره المقبله من قنا
وتحديدا من دندره